I entered communities as I was coming up
and was like wow everyone here is bigger
than me and then I was able to through
achievement rise through that and then I
lost context with that group and so I
think there's just more free agency a
friendship that happens on your climb up
because you're just moving between
strata more frequently than it is that
if I settled at one of these levels then
I would eventually find all the people
at that rung I think your tolerance or
your standard for friends raises it's
only a problem if you'd hate it I don't
what don't you hate you don't hate the
fact that sort of people come and go
that some of these relationships are
kind of transient yeah it just doesn't
bother me and that's fine